tausende freiwillige leisten heute
ehrenamtlichen putzdienst und zwar am
rhein
zum zweiten mal findet dort die wohl
größte müllsammelaktion europas statt
titel reihen cleanup auf 1237 kilometern
ist am ufer einiges liegen geblieben
besonders problematisch ist plastik bis
zu 380 tonnen schwemmt der rhein jedes
jahr in die nordsee gut die hälfte des
plastiks in den weltmeeren wird über
flüsse dorthin transportiert nur ein
kleiner teil schwimmt sichtbar an der
oberfläche
das meiste jedoch ist unsichtbar denn
durch sonnenstrahlen also uv licht
wasser und bewegung zersetzt sich das
plastik in winzige partikel im mikro
plastik damit es erst gar nicht so weit
kommt schwärmen die müllsammler aus
peter böhme berichtet metall heute baum
müll tausende zigarettenkippen schon
interessant was immer und am rhein so
alles um licht student in china findet
party müll einen grillrost und reste von
pizza kartons
[Musik]
ihr habt ja hergebracht warum könnt das
nicht auch wieder mitnehmen ist lehrer
als vorher also leichter ein paar meter
weiter isabel rath mit ihren kindern
müllsammeln als erziehungs option um den
kindern zu zeigen dass unsere umwelt
schützenswert ist und dass jeder ein
bisschen was dazu beitragen muss rein
cleanup den rein sauber machen das
geschah heute an über 100 orten entlang
des rheins über 20.000 freiwillige
doppelt so viele wie letztes jahr zogen
los um aufzuräumen
wie hier in mainz ich finde wir
produzieren so viel mühe machen uns
wenig gedanken darum muss am ende landet
und ich finde es wichtig sich auch zu
engagieren nicht nur darüber
nachzudenken und zu meckern jeder sollte
sich an die eigene nase fassen und
überlegen was er kauft was er an plastik
konsumiert
plastikmüll becher tüten flaschen die
flüsse sind die fließbänder die den müll
in die meere bringen vögel und fische
können qualvoll daran verenden
mir ist klar dass wir mit einer aktion
wie dieser auch wenn wir 200 tonnen müll
einsammeln die welt nicht retten werden
aber ich glaube dass wir da ein signal
aussenden können und dieses signal heißt
leute ändert euer bewusstsein der rhein
und seine ufer sind heute ein bisschen
sauberer geworden im nächsten jahr wird
wieder aufgeräumt